hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play blacks
know I am sick unfortunately it was
bullying in a matter of time I actually
called myself out on this because um
earlier I was singing hi I haven't
gotten sick all year maybe I'll get
through it and then you know because I
said that all hell broke loose in my
nasal area I don't know anyway I
remember you guys wrote in the comments
something I was supposed to do here but
I forgotten you know I can't I can't be
held accountable for this stuff that
thing's still there
no yes I don't know who knows you guys
said something whoa
what done no food wear suit what this
looks like a cave to hell no thank you
uh-huh don't leave Jim is that like some
motivation to work out yeah I don't do
that all right I'll solve that problem
about never entering hey hey hey I'll
mark you so funny I don't trust that at
all that looks like something straight
out of The Twilight Zone
no thank you I'll leave I'll leave
yes please gooo head man bald man war I
like it
knife all my fault oh I thought that's
initiation I thought that they'd
inflation's and I was like wait hug and
then Space Marine of course uh-huh
super-powered Space Marine the reason
why I'm not taking a break today is
because I've never missed an upload date
no thank you
oh yeah this'll end well the bathroom
scenes all right I've never missed an
upload day for as long as I have been
making videos on YouTube
and I don't intend to let its little
cold or whatever I have stopped me by
that one open huh
so the table what tile oh I see ah ha ha
ha wait hang on
hello baby hi I knew you some of you
were expecting me to do that hello baby
mama huh I got cough drop so I'm good to
go
um I'll some weirdos out there like ooh
I wonder what his exact symptoms are
what your weirder
what the hell hey why'd that just fall
down look what the hell all right
who this person seems dead emission
check yup dead okay ah let's see what we
got here I'm gonna try to finish this
game today
cuz I gotta go celebrate Christmas with
my family and on top of being sick what
am i doing hi this is locked I can't I
can't use this fine I'll go move on if
you're gonna be an a-hole just take it
go away
the door is unlocked good ah ah
anything else I'm supposed to get here
wait was that I see something Lowen I
might speedling handle on the door I
guess okay nevermind I need to find I'm
sort of I guess I need to go in one of
these rooms it look like the horror
death from all above I don't know I see
all these heaters but they're not
working hmm I mean I really wish I
remembered what you guys told me to do
that would be helpful though there's
another one nightfall and for her
monkeys noodlin yeah yeah okay what's in
here
anything anything okay what did you guys
say Oh some bout mark you're so awesome
um I wish I was as cool as you I know
everybody does but only a few people
can't be exposed me somebody lost one
who was in there what was that I didn't
see anything then again everything's in
pastel cuz I'm losing a lot of blood or
something okay I would like to be able
to see I thought I just solved that
problem and that's going here ooh oh oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh yay look at wait
who's that who's that
Slenderman should be on the day
move what the hell wait what oh oh turn
it on turn it back on now turn it back
on I want it to go back on please thank
you maybe I like that I like that a lot
oh that's real nice ha ha ha cams
looking for anything small that I might
miss on this shelving area okay oh oh
come on all right I got a rusty chisel
what I do is that can i crack open the
can i crack open the computer with that
huh I don't know I don't know no let's
just try going back the way I came I
suppose uh-huh or not the way I came
this other area I locked here that has
hang on let me see if there's any juice
left in this year might be enough get me
back into normal color range yeah
oh I feels good huh I'm sure I'll lose
it in a few hits don't you worry
hope there's like an unlimited freezer
Peter things this way you were telling
me about desire and you knew about this
I probably was who is pricing really
important
uh I'd really like a heater right now
finally winter finally came where I am I
mean it's horrible almost two inches of
snow and there there's actually Sun that
you know a little bit sticking to the
ground not much you know most but you
know a little bit is horrifying for us
Ohioans oh I don't mean high oh no
that's a nice-looking teddy bear I don't
see anything in here wait was it
hello what is this welcome to I'm Luke
Dave you love nah okay this doesn't help
me at all no ma'am what sleep I know
everything because I didn't get any
sleep that night haha haha nice owl that
nothing here there's all bunch of crap
was you supposed to be was it praying
room oh okay
that's a rug for uh Islamic fellows to
go to Mecca yeah point if spray tobacco
that's right I remember okay okay wait a
minute wait worth why did that shut down
on me is that is that where I came from
did that just okay good that's not okay
that's some completely different
um sorry I'm really wish you wouldn't
I really wish I wasn't sick right now
I've tried to first win for Kazakh Stan
Wow
nice abs lady look at that geez man okay
God bear wraps and I ever hope to get
all right so am I missing something you
I feel like I'm missing numbing I've got
this rusty who's it what's it did I get
it cuz he doesn't not showing up on my
inventory but I got and everything looks
much brighter now that everything is in
normal color so let me take another look
I dunno I know you told me some dumb
come here it's slightly colors are so
prettyy now it really is much nicer when
things aren't aren't in black and white
I mean as atmosphere cuz that can be I
don't see anything there when we go back
maybe I missed something in the
emergency can the immersion immersion
self was it
check out here was that hello baby how
are you doing weirdo lifting up movies
ah
this lady you've killed herself or died
I'm gonna guess dead it's kind of you
know some that would be interesting I'll
go
no no no this got me oh I know it
sounded like I was blowing my nose but
what I was actually doing was fighting
off a horrifying monster that was taking
over my body and I won so you're all
welcome I'm still here oh oh oh hello
naked ladies
that's art an ideal it idyllic scene
okay I had to miss some here son
I'm not right that's a nice warm glow I
wish I would have known about that
before everything was all dark I hated
myself
hey stop whoa hello I got a hammer and a
chisel what do I do about nose Oh get
ready oh that was red I would have never
known so I got a hammer a chisel you're
al what am I gonna do about that mmm
it's giving barmy all right feel bad for
me oh subscribe favorite like because I
know I will persevere I have a hammer
and chisel I'm assuming assuming that
I'm supposed to crack open a rock with
these things
maybe that's all I'm supposed to get
over here I'm a ninja just assume that
okay so I went left and went right
the back way in the front way and I go
around and then know the hanger I need
to have a one fuel I need the ignition
key need a nav map and at red link we're
gonna fight all these oh [ __ ] is he
hello stay illuminated oh I knew about
that that's in here not going here
what's in here I don't remember going in
here uh okay um see if I go that way I
don't think there was anything besides
juices generators and was there anything
in the generator room that I still
needed that is the question it was a
fight going on here that is the question
the question - oh yeah hello Ben okay uh
I I don't know I don't know I just um I
don't think there was anything else in
the generator so let me go out the other
end
I've been easier to go the other way but
whatever no no it would have been fine
this way hi even know how long I've been
going seems forever I can't drag on when
you're sick Bob are you there hello a
bar bar oh yeah huh Oh God okay soon as
I get out to here from the exuberantly
long loading screen I'll take a look at
the map I will defer judgment to you
guys probably more entertaining just
watch me ha ha ha ha uh-oh is that more
entertaining for you guys was end up
weird the map I redid my there's map ok
so here's the map the hangars up there
ok yeah there was nothing in the way you
are here there's a toolshed toolshed was
just a ruins
let me go look at it the hanger let me
go take a look at the hanger I got
enough health to waste go wander it into
snow for a little bit and I can just
load up my Saviour the other one like
what is the dealio why just the snow
it's blocked by snow was there another
door out go it hurt so bad
Gold I know what you feel like even
though you're like in the middle of
Greenland my 31 degrees and slightly
snowy its equivalent somehow yeah that's
it I can't see anything
I don't think there's anything here
there is no hope there is no hope all is
lost what is that wait what is that
what done ah good oh that's what you
meant by I could light barrels ah hate
me view out to heat okay too much heat
news I hate me ah that's gorgeous
tah hoopty yada who do lay some kind of
barricade underneath this way
yeah actually there is hang on let me
try this maybe this is a thing pound
maybe this is a thing if I had a
flashlight I sure would love to see it
help this is not a thing it's not a
thing this is not a thing um no oh
that's just part of the out never mind
never mind I'm just I'm losing my mind
yeah this would have been nice to know
about a long time ago well I mean I knew
about it but I'm an idiot
ergo why would I ever listen to any good
advice you you guys had done no you
can't do anything you can't back jazz me
I'm sick all right I think I'm all out
of time I've been going in circles I
don't know what I'm doing my brain is
half scrambled I can't I can't think for
anything so uh just uh tell me what to
do and I'll do it
you know just if you feel if you feel
like I deserve to finish this cape just
tell me - I'll say I'll remember next
time walk me through the end and I'll
get there so thank you all for bearing
with my sick ways maybe wasn't even
worth uploading today but thank you
again for watching it as always I will
see you in the next video bye-bye
all the top